thanks for joining everybody markiplier
thing did he say did he say the
markiplier thing
no way yeah I just people doing me I'll
give you one good old alright here we go
hello everybody my name is markiplier
yeah we shut mutant look at the [ __ ]
mouth oh my god it's so foggy so we're
in a good ski kamesh ski yeah we're not
actually go to kamesh key okay okay the
new town as soon as soon as you can jump
go jumping and bombing F coming if BAM F
right now you'll jump out oh it's pretty
far far flight so you might have to aim
up pretty flower flight C to Zambia is
following us yes good thank you clever
ha wait watch out that's twice as many
as you can handle
[Laughter]
thank you I hate to tell you this about
your mic is kind of crackly for me I'm
not you know you're fine you're fine man
I don't want to listen to that [ __ ] this
whole time is that better no we is
someone getting that okay food school
weight issues weight emotional problems
that need to work out without aggression
wait big smell wow that's just rude guys
problem no problem with worried never
[Music]
no problem with wee-wee whooping sounds
like when you talk like that that you do
have a problem with I just feel like I'm
sensing some sarcasm or something like
yeah yeah I can't help no no problem and
do keep in mind I will treat you nicely
you said dookie dookie in mind bro that
Street Street Oh zombie chased it down
guys what the [ __ ] it's down I'm awful
well yeah you just realizing this now
hey zombie friend yeah anything is
allowed I'm trying to balance it since
it's you need a first aid kit I got a
first aid kit here I've got one can you
watch me for a second I you think yeah
we should go we've really fired we're
gonna die to the circle aren't we yeah
you probably should put away the weapon
together forgot stuff X X
excellent give it to you do you think
you can get it on your own it would be
really pathetic of us to die to us it
will be not the best reflection on us as
human being I have a u-az up and zoom
opens ooh
straight at you have full speed mark Oh
perfect I saw a gif of someone going
under it so I'm gonna do that no I don't
want driving okay oh that is blue how'd
that get here so quickly
oh goodness yes
wait we're [ __ ] out of here come here
man come on Jesus here we go Bobby would
be even more embarrassing if we got this
vehicle and then you crashed and then
can't see nothing there's fog there's
some sort of thick air left that's not
right in front of us Oh them oh them are
you scared
perfect good idea there's one crawling
right here you think you can hide no
it's too late for you Christ oh the only
one of memory around here I said let's
take two what then why did three of you
go to one and me go I don't think you
said that I think you're just making me
seem like this one was full of gas so
this was a good choice yeah yeah all
right we're gonna stop here and heal up
for a sec okay I see zombies at
Northeast where Oh between the hay bales
that I'm running right towards he's
writing but twixt them yeah that big
stack there's a building over there you
want to go lookee at daddy yeah
following Bob's lead hey we're still
alive I'm not I didn't say lead like
following Bob's lead you know I wasn't
waiting it up that was I was just saying
as a fact we were falling on your zombie
I'm covered to help
oh that sounds bad there's a couple well
that one went on the building for some
reason good job guys oh there's more
yeah there's more out by mark where's
one up on the hill to the north I say
I've just been seeing mark oh hey
there's a bunch of ammo down here oh I
feel like a big man no and I have no
time to heal now oh why is Wade driving
let's do this we're we're survivors look
at us that sound is that green yeah I
don't like the way that sounds it's the
school animal you've been there before
yeah but I you never described it that
way before
just cuz we've been there Hartman like
if we go to Grandma's house and then we
go back and you suddenly call it murder
grandma I'm gonna be a little worried
about it you know what I mean
yeah that's even worse murder me murder
meatball murder me ma we probably
shouldn't split up Bobby's right here at
15 behind you mark hmm all right just
stay stay as a group watch your watch or
sixes let's go let's just start clearing
these buildings out okay that's ami but
he didn't die you didn't die all the way
all right I'll go I'll go
I'm gonna go straight to the top of this
one oh I hear him they're talking
they're in this they're in here there
are zombies in here I heard voices turn
that on they see us
trying to come in the front door here
okay realize that we can hear everything
I'm gonna go circle around I don't have
their voices on shine no mark mark don't
get isolate don't get I saw okay okay
you got it you go
oh wait wait I know where one is no it's
right under here let's quickly see
that's why I just tolerate I still here
don't give us a hug
did they [ __ ] up our Jeep oh [ __ ] I hope
they didn't think of that
no what do you and your not optimism
will find another book oh I have no
heels with this gonna suck isn't it it's
gotta be vehicles around here I just
hope they're not all totally [ __ ]
it's a Dacia it's not [ __ ] get in get
in get in turn only good call good call
good call I got a motorcycle you guys go
let's go I'm dying here Mark's gonna die
no no I'm fine go go go I'll live zomb
Oh Oh free points guys I mean I really
just need to catch the blue is what I
need to do yeah I believe in you I
believe in you
my life is in your hands I'm fine I'm
fine I'm fine I'm
I'm tougher than this holy [ __ ] run
straight back to further car okay we
should heal boost do whatever you need
to do right now yeah okay love doing
Italy Ivan only bandages I see a lot of
Tommy is south of us holy [ __ ] everyone
just ever just Gatorade up that's [ __ ]
know what I'm in the vehicle good god
they can [ __ ] up the cars yeah so tense
I was inches Oh didn't shoot shoot oh my
god nice shot nice shot holy [ __ ] try
this this is like almost final circle
stuff yeah why are we driving Park this
Park this no we're like two feet away
from the circle driving it's just giving
us away Park the goddamn car okay we're
here already this is it are broken here
that's enough to kill 74 people here
Jack I'll drop some more here no no it's
fine I have four we really need to start
like thinning this herd we're about to
be in a position where bad no it's fine
well the good side of it for still and
we just we really need to start getting
some kills is the thing okay yep hunt
this is not yeah this is the worst yeah
there are 74 zombies currently in this
area are at boys
yeah let's hunt let's head south around
the circle and try and hunt a little bit
yeah I'm gonna there's gotta be some of
them just laying prone let's just let's
just hunt as a pack try and get a lot of
them hopefully I'm behind you like 30 or
40 Delta Oscar Mike let's see anything
and all I hear is wind that's terrifying
and the NRF voice Christ our voice chat
is on
oh yeah how how are we not hearing them
they're all together I like what you
just get this is bang bang we're gonna
get to the circle and then just get like
mom I'm gonna kill any zombies of people
yeah I can do it can you know it's gonna
happen
freaking out fine it's fine Wade
everything is fine I feel like you say
that a lot it's fine Wade and it
affected we say that a lot is concerning
yeah it's fine yeah why have we seen
none I don't know this is awful I am
maybe they're all shaking in my chair
right now the doors are broken there
well we could use this road as like our
port point of the circle and a little
clear space to hold I'm watching the
houses did you guys hear something no or
something I'm hearing maybe mumbles in
the distance
should we try and should we try and bait
them out where we should see them from
there's some 30 I threw a smoke yeah the
blue is here none of them have appeared
are you [ __ ] kidding me right now I
see movement at 30 again somebody in a
bush these bushes are so good for hiding
in here I scared him up up there good
enough how are you down because one
rushed me oh yeah Wade was down by his
nemesis one zombie all right mom I would
shoot ain't the one screaming if you oh
you guys you guys they're all pushing oh
my god there are so many coming from
north of us guys holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god
God Jesus Christ
this seems oh my god holy [ __ ]
[Music]
somebody's just yelling for the Horde
I'm fine just don't tell them that I'm
here he's go prone mark how did you get
away from them do not they're coming for
me
they know I'm here Jesus Christ - good
god
[Music]